[Music]
this challenge is going to involve
engineering force vectors and some light
mountaineering you're going to need to
construct a bridge strong enough to
safely transport a vehicle from one side
to the other the vehicle is going to be
constantly traveling along its path and
it'll take 90 minutes to reach the
bridge so time is of the essence your
bridge needs to be sturdy but don't take
too long or when the vehicle gets there
it's not going to make it across
[Music]
to succeed in this challenge you're
going to need to be able to successfully
design a bridge that can handle all of
the forces that you're going to place on
it when this vehicle goes across so
there are a couple of key things that we
want to think about number one we want
to think about the strength of the
materials that you're working with what
makes them strong and in what ways they
are strong and then we want to think
about your design and the geometry of it
and how we're going to handle all the
different forces that are going to be at
play make sense
okay so let's start by thinking about
this
you've got a piece of paper there and a
marker i'd love you all just to draw a
bridge any bridge maybe one you've seen
it can be sort of cartoony if you like
don't worry about making it too
complicated because the whole idea is
there are many different kinds of
bridges and i just want to see what
comes up from you guys off the top of
your head can you go ahead and draw one
for me can i ask you all to hold up your
pictures and do it so not just me um can
see but actually all the rest of you can
just do a bit of a quick comparison all
different bridges yeah feeling happy
okay great put them down for a second
now what's brilliant is i think we maybe
have uh we've got pretty much every kind
of type of bridge right as you know
there are three main kinds of bridges
and i want to talk through each one so
that you can understand the principles
at work underneath them okay if you've
got you know a beginning and an end you
can see where you're building from and
to here on the challenge so if you're
going to start here and end over here
okay you want to have basically this
beam going across and you've got these
sorts of structures here something like
this which will distribute the forces
okay now how is this going to work well
you're actually getting a weight on top
of here
and it's placing stress and strain on
the bridge okay what kind of stressful
strength is actually two different types
that you maybe have experienced right
it's pushing down if this isn't strong
enough what do you think is going to
happen what would you describe is going
to happen to the shape of the bridge
it'll like sink yeah perfect it's
actually going to kind of sink downwards
isn't it right so what we're talking
about here is tensile strength so it's
kind of being stretched out as it were
it's going to turn into let's use
another color
it's going to turn into something like
this this is that sinking that you
described and eventually it's going to
break like as you can see this curved
length is longer than what it looks like
when it's just straight and it gets
longer and longer until it can't get
longer anymore and it will fall apart
does that make sense so that's why you
can see and you several of you did this
on your bridges you've got these trusses
here and these triangular shapes what do
they do as this weight is coming down
you can see the direction that the
forces are distributed to right it's
sort of along these lines here
and what's great about these triangles
is they're all kind of matched together
so can you see how for example this
triangle here
it's applying a force to the right and
it's balanced by this force from the
other triangle next to it going to the
left makes sense now obviously there's
still downward force and that's why you
need to construct it you know with a
muscle strength and using your materials
carefully but that's how you can balance
this out system just cave okay let's
have a look i wonder if i'm coming can
you hold up yours
for all of us so we can see all right
so this is not a truss bridge what is
this do you guys know what it's called
very roughly string bridge a string
bridge i mean you can actually
physically use string to do this and
what you've got here is sort of like two
tower looking things right and then
suspending the bridge are these well
they might be strings or cables or
anything like that right now because it
is suspended this is often called a
suspension bridge right now what you've
got here is let's think again about
where the forces are going and what
actually there's different kinds of
strength going on okay
firstly you've got
this here's your bridge
and it's actually being held up by these
strings or these cables so have a think
of this not a rhetorical question you
saw where the forces were going here
where are the forces going in what
direction are they going from the bridge
to the strings or cables picture it
imagine you are standing on there right
so you're making the bridge go down
where are the strings trying to go to
try and keep it they're actually going
up right so they're sending their force
upwards like so okay same sort of idea
that we were talking about before
tensile strength um if there's too much
that's pushing you know that sort of
thinking you're describing before
um these strings will get sort of pulled
and pulled and pulled eventually they
might break if it's too heavy but hold
on a second they can't just like just go
up into the sky and like where do they
go from there okay and that's why again
if you hold yours up come in you can see
why those towers are so important what
might they be made of in bridges you've
seen before what do you see they're made
of concrete concrete steel really strong
materials right so i'm going to try and
make this a bit bolder here
so you've got kind of these
big strong structures but this is
actually working very differently think
about this these strings or cables are
being stretched so that's the tensile
strike we're talking about before
but this column here it's not being
stretched out it's actually being
squashed it's being
compressed so this is actually called
compressive strength so when you think
about the materials you've got you've
got the balsa wood you've got some
cardboard right they actually have
different material properties that have
you know a strength for stretching and
also a strength for squashing okay i'm
just having a look across okay um i
might go to jed can you hold up your one
for us okay this is an interesting
design a bit of a combination going here
is that shape across the top and also
page you were drawing something very
similar as well
it's that shape across the top that i'm
interested in what would you call that
what name would you give to that kind of
shape an arch yeah that's exactly right
so if we have a think about
an arch bridge right and we've got a lot
of famous arch bridges around the world
for example the sydney harbour bridge is
an arch okay it's actually a very
particular kind of shape and it's very
clever right watch this
if you take
a heavy sort of uh elastic kind of
object like this right and if you let it
hang under its own weight this actually
makes a particular kind of shape that's
very important to building bridges um
what would you guess that this shape
looks like what do you reckon kind of
like a semi circle yeah if i held it
kind of like this right with um these
ends vertical it does look like a
semicircle
another shape that you guys have
encountered before that sort of looks
vaguely familiar starts with a p
could be a parabola parabola but
actually weirdly it is neither a
semicircle nor a parabola it's a shape
called a catenary now catenary actually
means chain that's why we've got this to
illustrate if you were to take this
shape right i wonder if you just have a
look here right
and if you turn this catenary upside
down
you get this particular looking arch and
what's brilliant about it is
you can see where the forces are going
here these ones are going up and then
down these ones going down and then in
diagonals
what's brilliant about this catenary is
it perfectly sends
all of its forces
out along the arch and so this can be
incredibly strong some of the oldest
bridges that we've seen around the world
if they've lasted for centuries
can pretty much guarantee
it's one of these kinds of shapes
because they're incredibly durable
you might see some of them made out of
perhaps you know stone brick that kind
of thing because we've been able to
manufacture and construct with that for
a long time or if you have a thinker the
materials that you have access to if you
have something that can go this entire
distance and is sort of flexible enough
to actually make this shape then if you
can design it properly it'll maintain
the weight of whatever you put on it so
long as it's strong enough materials
okay we have these three different kinds
of bridges that all work slightly
differently the truss bridge uses a
simple construction that sends the
forces off into whatever kind of
triangular lattice that you design
you've got the suspension bridge which
has to have these very strong pillars
that will hold up whatever kinds of
cables or other materials will suspend
the bridge in the air and then lastly
you've got the arch bridge which sends
the forces along the structure itself so
you can see that's why there's none of
these triangular supports it's actually
this curved shape the catenary that does
the job and supports the weight
to succeed in this challenge you want to
think about what kind of a bridge that
you design you can think about you have
access to the weights to test these out
and see you know before the vehicle gets
there whether it's going to be strong
enough and you want to think about
whichever design that you pick how is it
working how does it take advantage of
the materials you've got and exactly how
they're strong
good luck can't wait to see what you
build and what you plan
stress test stress test all right let's
go guys ready
[Music]